موعده او توقيت وصول الدبابات الغربيه الى
اوكرانيا ونشرها في جبهات القتال العامل
الابرز لاحراز تقدم حيث يتخوف خبراء
عسكريون من عدم وصولها في الوقت المناسب
اي السباق الهجوم الروسيه المتوقع في
فبراير وسطه مجموعه الدبابات التي يحتمل
وصولها اولا هي الدبابات البريطانيه
لاربعه عشره تشالنجر 2 ورجعت صحيفه نيوتنز
ان تصل في اواخر مارس على ان تبدا عمليه
التشغيل وايصال هذه الدبابات للخطوط
الاماميه في اي برول او ما يعلى ابعد
التقطيع دبابات لا يوبا اثنين الالمانيه
الصنع التي تعاهدت بها المانيا وغيرها من
حلفاء اوكرانيا الاوروبيين قد تصل في نفس
الوقت تقريبا لكن ليس دفعه واحده فالجدول
الزمنيه يعتمد على سرعه كل الحكومه لكن من
شبه المؤكد ان وصول دبابات ابرامز
الامريكيه سيستغرق وقتا اطول ويتمثل بشهور